i have no beef with no rappers i'll be
trolling yeah what happened with the no
cap thing huh talk about it this was
like was this last night the night
before they were like copenhagen you're
hanging out with pawn you're hanging out
with a.d i'm sure the flickers flowing
yeah with trump
yeah yeah i'll be getting drunk a lot i
like getting drunk damn [ __ ] with no
i'm saying the [ __ ] and [ __ ] i will
sit down man you know i like drinking
and [ __ ]
but with the look with that little
situation i do
[ __ ] up situation that's a [ __ ] up
situation man i don't want to explain do
you regret
uh do you regret like i don't regret
should i say i don't know regretting
once i see it i said he felt my own
greatest aj like i hate that i did it
like that though
no
that makes sense
you're in the moment you're not even
like understanding that like not even in
a moment like
that [ __ ] was on my chest i wanted to
get that [ __ ] out it was like just
yeah
cause people don't even understand
what's going on for real so they build
and they own look
you know i mean you throw something like
that out there people are going to come
up with their own
i would troll them don't know playing
when they [ __ ] no playing man that was
a big a joke
fair enough
i mean do you feel like because
obviously you're from a place like
alabama uh
a lot of different cities but the
culture in alabama in terms of just like
hip-hop is like really starting to
finally take off um
lots of superstars out of alabama shout
out to uh the homie young blue yeah yeah
man um
but uh
is it is it easier to beat for somebody
from your own city it feels like that's
always the [ __ ] like you always have the
biggest issues with people who are from
where you're from is that you think
that's the case because then you get
shot like
yeah yeah i got shot
oh [ __ ] though it was [ __ ] fighting at
the club
you just were in the wrong place at the
wrong time wrong play wrong good bro
right wrong play wrong time but as far
as like the question
i don't think i just feel like it'd be
[ __ ] that'd be going on like everything
like
the naked i ain't to see everything
that's going on especially on instagram
that's fair there'll be a lot of [ __ ]
going on people don't be knowing about
you know my feelings beginning
his music is fire your music is fired it
would be crazy y'all work together we
did we got a song we got an old song
kyle demons
hmm so at a certain point in time things
were okay
yeah cause i had came back to sit on
some
fam you know i was in california so when
i came back to mobile i want somebody
someone telling in my seat i'm trying to
get down you know that's fair yeah i
already had a little blood and [ __ ]
uh-huh so i'm like man like i'm trying
to work with everybody but once i
started paying attention
and seeing what's going on and [ __ ]
[ __ ] went right